the videogame Dennis Smith and Anton
church have been playing together
there's a cowboy play opportunity coming
up for change a heretic is the lead
again yeah look at that - spreading to
the corner setting his feet JJ reddick
stay attached to him he is yet to miss
the shot oh the dive on the floor loose
ball this is a blue-collar hard-working
tight JJ Redick gets down
with the potential for point collides
been in his on his side here's the Val
here what a beautiful shot by JJ reddick
who struggled on Tuesday in Boston grant
I would say is the point guard by
default e encounters both McConnell and
and bead TJ with a steal Redick another
three yes
missing the three the Sixers can settle
here they have 14 to shoot Redick
another three yes I'll tell you what I
thought it was a heat check but guess
what wait Sixers get themselves their
first hoop of this third quarter
compliments of bolts Redick afraid yes
JJ Redick has it going on tonight from
beyond 6 of 7
hang on Oliver coming in for a landing
[Music]
[Applause]
in front of that defender Robert never
able to cover back in that place Redick
for three yes JJ reddick coming up large
again in the Sixers by one to shoot
dirties again from the other end of the
floor Redick it's for three yes
[Applause]
we did have a whistle afterwards as far
as I'm concerned that the three is going
to count
brennick
[Applause]
JJ reddick in all his majesty
buries the three will get one more of
the line a lot of that down the stretch
of games I'll give you the great offense
but that's kind of a fortunate resolve
look at the little moonbeam shot that
goes in
how big has reddit been for the Sixers
it's not a big enough sample size so
Alex for might be looking at all these
numbers but he's using his intuition you
know I don't know many people who would
have thought in his six innings
there's Redick again nobody's covering
you so you're not worried about the shot
getting blocked so do what comes
naturally and that's really a natural
motion exactly as JJ reddick cans the
three six there's only two team fouls
Redick unleashing and drilling the three
for effect
hit the wood trying to get the free
throw at the expense of Garrett temple
[Music]
[Applause]
boys redick throwing up a prayer as the
heat really rest
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
be quite the catch still has it would
put his shoe on fully the trucks of
three goes and he's going to take that
shoe and I think he's gonna throw it
away he's holding it right now Rennick
playing defense with one shoe on and one
shoe off
he's calling switches in there well one
way to get that shoe back on is to
commit a foul that's a third shoe we see
quite with it on fully mark lje go to
stop playing thirds of it and see
someone call a fort who is it
but shoeless 259 to be exact
shell out here at Wells Fargo Center 5
is JJ Redick drills the 3 to 4 JJ
weakside Redick
[Applause]
and the Sixers with their parsley since
they led to nothing me times your
earlier point about to break no hits the
three
yeah the heavy did not have that in
Lawrence mark assaults comeback glad it
with MB Redick for three got it JJ
reddick boy after missing his first five
shot number nine for Philadelphia but
off the turnover on the inbounds Redick
fires away that one in JJ Redick his
first reporter JJ Redick long distance
connects on a three it's been open at
both ends of the floor
now right now with Riddick hitting that
jump shot Redick for the lead
[Applause]
condiments jdj ready to get a transition
and me stepping right into that perfect
pass from sympathy you know right now
he's shooting it at 44% so you got to
give him a lot of credit from deep how
did that over the hand outstretched arm
of Marcus smart come life the last 10
games took a DNP in charlotte the corner
will go and the foul now Redick with a
chance for a four-point play here career
season that JJ Redick is having there's
the contact by Korver the shooting woes
for Donovan Mitchell continued brennick
leader from three-point range
timeout Quin Snyder and on that shot
using every bit of that wrist Accord
knocking it down Redick that is for
three and he delivers JJ Redick that's
an excellent three-point shooter very
good catching and shoot guy speaking of
which it is who etic nailing the three
on the ket should shoot the Sixers by
the way a few late getting zoom there
and Smith lady getting to him as well JJ
with that quick really believable steps
and there's one season as a sooner is
holding the good hustle off the
offensive glass
it is a drill-down it
for jdj Renick only a second three and a
close unbelievable amount unless they
get to spend a short period of time home
and then they're across the pond as you
mentioned JJ Redick is fouled eight for
Lord Noah Vonleh will go to the line for
one more
first rule you're always taught on
defense Simmons again giving it up
Redick it's for three yes the shot clock
running down
[Applause]
I'm 19 we assist away from a triple
double he has some reason timer that
goes for us and his wife tangle-free off
it goes JJ reddick come on now don't it
doesn't count
ready got it back from ends bead and JJ
reddick ripping forward come on now you
got plenty of time here good good shot
opportunities Simmons check back into
the game during the line alright and JJ
reddick banked it in couple of assists
the jump here is going right back to him
too
and downpours Simmons the catch
[Music]
that you can tell what pop was basically
saying I'm not concerned about office
we're going to school we've got to do a
better job eventually again three and a
half seconds on the shot clock and all
of a sudden Redick throws this up over
the contestant hand of all RIT Aldrich
hopped on the floor to direct traffic
ready to talk
[Applause]
it's the screen but it's just a switch
the patience of Ben Simmons Redick
knocks down the jump shot gets the
contact going to the line for the
four-point play is having a breakout
season he's really become a very good
shooter it's a more well-rounded
absolutely Rennick
it's for three and he delivers JJ Redick
his first three of the game the two-man
game JJ JJ getting him back from Mike
muscala but you see every bunker
is that hard on him give me some room
what a beautiful pass from indeed out
the efficient
26:12 out of 15 from the field that was
what we call a wet clock down to six
Butler gives it up here's Redick got
cousins autumn Redick again
one that could put this one away
five-point lead for Philadelphia Redick
pretty nice pass by the Connell Kuzma
has feed off a little bit Simmons on the
break finds ready maybe for four
what a shot JJ reddick took the hit
[Music]
mr. winter our game has ever seen
without a doubt
[Applause]
Butler reading tips for three
tough to get up for you've got to
dispatch those teams reading thinking
three there it is have done it goes for
JJ reddick his spit three and six tries
give him 19 Redick for three he was
thought you could cut it did he call it
on night as he's trying to fight through
that scream that is a awkward looking
shot nonetheless and as loud as this
building spin all night Redick it's for
free
five on the shot clock for putler two on
the clock
Redick yes just the way they drew it up
they won this year by a combined six
points
she's the early flex formation Redick
that was for a three for JJ Redick no
but you don't get a rivalry if you have
full of history and last year even
though it was five games they went after
each other
Redick down the plea to answer defense
by Scott on Parris levert and he does
like to drive the basketball Redick yes
that was for three for JJ Redick who
joins the three-point shooting party
watch this Bend the cross-court pass
leading JJ especially against the Sixers
he's got 13 here in the first half which
adds about 46 seconds in line already
[Applause]
consecutive possessions to put the
Sixers upper left and a lot of people
think he is I think that's a perfect
example of it right there and people to
create well JJ reddick fouled hitting
the three first
all-time in NBA history in
three-pointers I'm just saying as you
can see been dribbling it to his side
under a minute now remaining before the
break Redick launching a 3d foul
how about this one soon as Ben crossed
half court I could see the JJ's eye and
B there's the double by lalawel camera
somebody's open reading it's four three
I don't know if anybody is better at
fading toddler weaves his way through
traffic reddit to fake Tijeras deflate
our play Center in Brooklyn game 3 6
Susan gets all tied at a game apiece
Redick has been very great Pat success
with this and see if the Sixers can make
the adjustment it's a good note this is
just too easy miss the one guy on the
floor that he before you get this big
free
but they're 9 minutes to go now in the
third quarter Philadelphia has cut it to
seven Redick is smoking hot JJ Redick
with his fourth three of the third
quarter Granick finds some space drills
in it well he there is no doubt a
different level of letters in the
postseason
[Applause]
defenders going to fall Pascal siakam
makes the switch his feet get tangled up
G chases I'm sorry that says it and
beads got the ball
[Applause]
I'll tell you what you talked about
weathering the storm opportunity to
react and contest on that shot rather
than get on the moon firing and knocking
it down
that was a huge basket that's why he's
being extra aggressive they're gonna
have to get contributions from others
here in this quarter look what the three
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content